près de 200 tireurs s'affronter ce
weekend au club de tir de voisin
lebretonux lors de la manche de
championnat régional de tir carabine et
pistolet à 10 m lors de ces concours le
calme est le maître mot chaque geste est
mimétré de la mise en place des pieds
sur le sol à la pose de la carabine sur
les épaules tout est fait avec calme et
précision pour ne pas être perturbé lors
du tir les qualités pour être bon
assidu
attentif qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait dire
encore pas avoir de stress calme posé et
maîtrce de soi surtout Pauline Laurent
découvre le tir en suivant son père près
des cibles la carabine devient vite sa
spécialité à 14 ans elle ne s'entraîne
désormais qu'une seule fois par mois
pourtant elle fait partie des 30
meilleures tireuses françaises de sa
catégorie ça représente quand même
beaucoup parce que je suis en
compétition
donc c'est une grande partie pour moi
parceen plus on met beaucoup sur mes
épaules donc ma
les gens du club donc c'est beaucoup
lors du concours ctinois la versaillaise
a porté son score à environ 360 points
sur 400 Pauline Laurent fait partie des
9 tireurs Vinois qualifi pour les
championnats de France du 5 au 9 février
prochain